yeah and so that that's actually the
thing i feel the most guilty about is
that we don't watch things together
because i feel like we should be but i
just
we don't want to watch the same things
why why do we have to do you get the um
sometimes i feel like there are things i
absolutely have to watch alone
in order to um fully um
how did i say um absorb like there are
things where i'm like i i really can't
have you watch this with me because i
feel like he might
paint the experience so like if it's
anything like he hates
anything lovey-dovey like even if it's a
really cool love story
he hates all of it he doesn't like love
stories in like a traditional sense like
two people kissing he's out he's checked
out so do you feel like if you're
watching that with him
you'll be so aware of how he's feeling
yeah
yeah yeah so like when when for instance
when jules and i will watch
like an old giuliana my name is oh yes
yes she's staying here
yeah she's thinking because love stories
are not real
no it's so fantasy-like but we have to
hide it we pause it when he comes back
upstairs and we won't watch it
until he leaves the room because he's
always he'll cut he'll do drive
watch that [ __ ] and they go oh that's
what love is
it's it's so romantic did you hate
brokeback mountain
i never saw it really i i couldn't see
it
it was slow it's not just that i i don't
know
what i don't know why but i just
couldn't see it that's
why he hates cowboys no no that's not it
there's some i don't know remember what
it was but i just didn't want to watch
it
you're afraid your dick would get hard
that's [ __ ] you okay let's watch it and
then i hold your dick
all right all right oh you know what i
will watch it
look i'll hover it over your dick and if
i even feel a little tip
yeah yeah all right then i'll know the
truth all right so with brokeback
mountain at the time
when that came out i was really not
doing well
in life and um i didn't have
access to it i don't you know so i just
went i went i'll pass on that
you know but because i think at the time
i had to go to a movie theater to watch
it i was gonna buy it
i don't know why but you know um i want
to watch it
because i don't have a problem with gay
love on television or film
but you have a problem with straight
love that's the point i was getting at
wait is brokeback mutton two guys that
are straight
no hooking up that well they're married
oh you're you're married
you're talking about straight no what i
don't like is when i was growing up
right little girls would be conditioned
to believe
that that's my knight in shining armor
yeah like my beautiful wedding yeah and
beautiful
those aren't the type of rom-coms that i
want i don't actually it all
feeds into that what i like is you know
tragedy yeah i love tragedy
you know like what like in dr zhivago at
the very end
of the movie you ever see dr zhivago no
is he the doctor that kills people
no that's kevorkian
he's a different doctor yeah i love dr
vogue
i think made in the 60s it was a just a
sweeping romantic
epic of a movie but at the end of the
movie you know
he loses contact i guess with his lover
dr zhivago does and for
20 years you know he doesn't know where
she is because it was a war that they
were separated
and when he's like an 80 year old man i
guess he's on a bus
and he sees his lover three seats in
front of him
so he gets up and she gets off of the
bus he gets off the bus too
and he's right behind her and he's
trying to tap her on the shoulder like
and he misses he has a heart attack he
dies and she doesn't even notice and
just she goes around the corner
oh that's love because see here's here's
my problem with his hair
love right there he finds he gets these
like
movies or shows that are not about
love at all but he'll somehow justify it
as
love how in a really complex way
so that when i have an issue in the
relationship about oh
like we're not showing each other that
much affection he'll be like well
if you look at dr zhivago like he'll
find like i said
he'll look like he'll be like if you
remember saving private ryan
and then he'll take he'll twist it so
that
it matches what he wants to do in a love
setting
which is not love like he doesn't want
to show
um you know the usual type of love he
doesn't want to express it in in a in a
what he calls a common way right does
that make you uncomfortable it's like
something like that i'm like i i get
what you i get it a little bit
i i i don't think you guys do i think um
you like michael black like that kind of
love
no that's too rom kami for that that's
even i love nico black
that's like fantasy that's what i'm
talking about me that i mean that's a
little hollywood version of what i'm
talking about yeah
but i love meet joe black that's what it
is at the end they can't be with each
other
yeah oh so that's mm-hmm you know it
doesn't like happy ending so is it like
house
like what are you saying that you're in
love with someone else and the fact that
you're with kalila that's like
he hopes that i die somewhere along the
way and that he because it's not a
it's not a reality it's not a reality i
it you know but you like the pain
i look i i i i identify with that kind
of pain
romantic pain yes yeah yes yeah i love
um listening to sad music
i remember being a young man listening
to sad music
rolling down the blinders on my day off
right sitting in a room with because
back then you could smoke in your room
i would smoke cigarettes drink coffee
listen to super
depressing music and just ponder life
sit there and smoke are you emo no i but
that's
emo it's not weird that like then you
say all that but you're also a stand-up
comedian
like you sit in sadness but you are your
job is laughter it's so
weird it's like why are why are we all
like that
because um at a point where i was
sitting there
when you live like that there comes to a
point where you go
uh oh in this society you know you
there's only two ways to do it it's
either stay in that
right and then with our way or then you
have to join
you know i mean society and sign up
for life right are you like and so i'm
like i'll sign up for life i guess
because i can't i couldn't bear my
parents disappointment
yeah i couldn't bear i also i had like a
lot of resentment toward high school
friends who all went to school and they
were all begun
become senators and [ __ ] in my head you
know
they're all you know are you friends
with your high school friends still
my best friend from elementary school
i'm still very close to and then there's
a couple but
i had like my college friends but not
really high school as much what was high
school like like did you wake what group
did you fall under
i was well i did theater and i kind of
bounced around
like i did the palm squad freshman year